(soft music)
- My name is Paula Varsano
and I'm professor of East
Asian Languages and Cultures
and Chair of the Foerster
Lectures Committee.
We're very pleased
along with the graduate council
to present Maryln Strathern
this year's speaker in the
Foerster Lectures Series.
As a condition of this request bequest
we're obligated to tell you
how the endowment
supporting the Foerster Lectures
on the Immortality of the Soul
came to UC Berkeley.
It's a story that exemplifies
in many ways
how this campus is linked
to the history of California
and the Bay Area.
In 1928
Miss Edith Zweybruck
established the Foerster Lectureship
to honor the memory
of Agnes A. Foerster
and Constantine E.A. Foerster.
Edith was a public school teacher
in San Francisco for many years,
and the teaching profession was to her
an opportunity to develop a true knowledge
and love
of the spiritual values of life
in the young mind
entrusted to her care.
Edith's beloved sister
Agnes A. Foerster
shared her high ideals and her hopes
as did Agnes' husband
Constantine E.A. Foerster.
A lawyer by profession,
Foerster was a man
of high intellectual achievements
and a rare personal charm.
Although he passed away at the age of 37
he had achieved an enviable place
at the San Francisco Bar
and was considered
one of it's most highly respected members.
For several years prior to his death
Foerster was law partner
of Alexander F. Morrison;
one of the most prominent
of San Francisco attorneys
for whom our own Morrison
memorial library is named.
In her last days
miss Edith Zweybruck
expressed an abiding interest
in the spiritual life
by creating this lecture series
on the subject
the Immortality of the Soul
or other similar spiritual subjects.
She left us
a little bit of leeway there.
She believed
that through medium of a great university
and the words of scholarly lecturers
she might bring new light upon a subject
that has interested the
world for centuries.
Thank you Edith Zweybruck.
And now about our lecturer.
Distinguished social anthropologist
Marilyn Strathern's first field site
was in Melanesia.
But it's fair to say
that she quickly revealed herself
to be an incisive ethnographer
of Euro-American society, too.
Casting over a period of some 40 years
a penetrating, yet generous eye
on questions ranging
from the representation
and practice of gender and kinship
which engaged her early on,
to the social significance
of reproductive technologies
and intellectual property, and beyond.
But there is a guiding thread
as there often is in the
work of a great scholar.
A fruitfully troubling line
of interrogation
that extends through her work.
Always in her sights
seems to be a questioning
of the very mechanisms
of knowledge formation
and knowledge formulation
that have long guided scholars
in her field.
Indeed,
and this is very impressive to me,
it was during her undergraduate years
that she first began interrogating
not just the objects of
anthropological research,
but the research practices themselves.
As described in one of the
many encyclopedia entries
dedicated to somehow capturing the breadth
of her contribution,
professor Strathern quickly arrived
at the point of asking
not so much
what specific objects or practices mean
but what does it mean
anthropologically to ask after them?
One of her best known works,
and she is the author of 15 books
is The Gender of the Gift,
published in 1988
and first drafted
while a visiting scholar here at Berkeley,
which she describes as a, quote
"Gentle deconstruction
"Of gender relations in New Guinea."
but which the encyclopedia
of theory and social and
cultural anthropology
describes as
doubly admonitory.
For it takes seriously
the fact
that constructs of gender
observed in the field
are not ready-made realities
waiting for analysis
rather, they are ever evolving
historically and socially
specific categories
in dynamic formation at all times
and not just in the observed society
but in that of the observer.
Her 1991 work, Partial Connections
expands this rather
dizzying line of thinking
into the larger question
of meaning making.
It's especially difficult
to do justice to this work
recognized almost since its publication
as a classic in the field.
It makes for challenging reading
at least for the likes of me,
and not least because language itself
comes under scrutiny.
And this,
from the perspective of
the student of literature
is a wonderful thing.
As I have done what can only be described
as reading in Strathern
I've come to think of her work
as offering a poetics
of social anthropology.
A body of scholarship
that takes fiction in all of its senses
seriously,
in which aesthetics and politics,
history and self-reflection
unfailingly bespeak her fine-tuned instict
for anthropology's basis
in relationality.
From what I understand
professor Strathern is,
as a matter of fact
currently working on a book
simply called Relations,
which I now cannot wait to read.
Marilyn Strathern received her B.A.
in archeology and anthropology
in 1963
and her Ph.D. in social anthropology
from Cambridge University.
Strathern held positions
at Australia National
University in Canberra,
and at the Girton and
Trinity colleges in Cambridge
as well as guest lecturing at UC Berkeley.
In 1985
she was appointed Chair
of the department of social anthropology
at Manchester University
before returning to Cambridge to serve
as William Wise professor
of social anthropology from 1991
until her retirement in 2008.
Other notable positions include
life fellow of Girton
College at Cambridge.
Honorary life president
of the UK ad common wealth association
of social anthropologists.
Presidential Chair
of the European Association
of social anthropologists.
Honorary fellow of Trinity College
and former member of the
Nuffield Council on Bioethics.
Regarding today's Foerster lecture
Souls in Other Selves,
and the Immortality of the Body
professor Strathern notes
"Sometimes the soul
"Seems a more precise
concept than the body."
This lecture
goes to a place and time
where kinds of beings
including food plants
have souls,
and where the bodily basis of life
is immortalized through cloning.
It comments on the way
present-day anthropology
brings fresh illumination
to what we thought we knew.
It's my pleasure to welcome
professor Marilyn Strathern to Berkeley.
(applause)
I should say back to Berkeley.
- [Marilyn] Thank you so much.
- My pleasure.
- I find it such a pleasure
to be in Berkeley again.
And in particular
to have the honor
of giving the Foerster lecture.
It's customary on such occasions
to make a gesture
towards the rubric of the lecture.
But I want to make more
than a gesture.
Adding to my warm thanks
to the graduate council
for the kindness of the invitation
thanks are also due
to Miss Edith Zweybruck
and the memorial she set up.
That she specified
the immortality of the soul
as a topic of contemplation
has led me to some anticipated thoughts
on matters
that one would imagine had
already been thought through
to exhaustion
if not actually discarded as unfit
for present-day thinking.
Anyway, I do mean thanks.
Because raising the question
of the immortality of the soul
becomes provocative
when the soul in question
is the archetype of soul
in the history of anthropological theory
namely the animist soul
as it became known in
the late 19th century.
And I refer to Edward Tyler's
landmark publication
on religion in primitive culture
in 1871.
Tyler demonstrated
that everywhere
people had ideas about souls.
With a personal
or diffused through notions
of ghosts and spirits
and encompassing the animation
of all kinds of beings
as though like people, they too had souls.
More than that
his thesis was that this apprehension
of the vital breath or spirit
pervading everything
extensions of what human
beings sensed of themselves
was the earliest sign
of a religious disposition.
It was at once the basis
of later religious development
hence the primitive, in his title;
and could be found here and there
in survivals.
Thus, he both brought animism
within the purview of the world's cultures
and revealed its formative role
in what his contemporaries regarded
as the higher religions.
Tyler's theory had a long life.
At to the end of the 19th century.
Now, in the course of
his extensive elaboration
Tyler does something rather surprising.
He suggests
that we would be imposing
later theological formulations
onto animism
to suppose that the
animist soul was immortal.
The animist soul is not immortal, he said.
Hmm.
The questions come crowding in.
So what is a soul?
So what is mortality?
And if the soul is not immortal,
is nothing immortal?
The very doctrine of soul
so central to theories of animism
is not a straight-forward
as it might seem.
The argument I eventually make
is rather simple.
And aspects of it have been articulated
many times.
But how we get to it
perhaps holds a little interest.
I'm going to set out various staging posts
on the way.
And at the outset
the posts will seem rather far apart.
So they have nothing
to do with one another.
But hopefully, they will
move closer together
as we proceed.
They are by way
of illuminations more than anything.
And if I may be so bold
may I suggest you just sit back
and relax,
and allow yourself to be carried
from one to the other.
The overall signpost
to our destination
comes from Ms. Zweybruck.
It reads, the signpost reads;
what might happen
if contra-Tyler
we dare as precisely
about immortality in animist thought.
And I'm going to refer
to one of the great regions of the world
who's indigenous cosmologist
are often described as animist,
namely Melanesia.
Staging post one.
The immortality of scholarship.
(laughter)
Let me start with a secular
enlightenment form of immortality.
One that certainly is
but is also a little more
than metaphoric.
I would not be finding much of interest
in this Victorian idea of animism
if it were not for its spectacular rebirth
in recent anthropological debate.
Often remarked upon with some surprise
animism now circulates
as a respectable term
for insight into the lives and ontologies
of certain peoples
as though the very concept
were risen from the dead.
What remains dead
is much of the evolutionary
apparatus of Tyler's thinking
as in the assumption
that present-day animists practices
indicate lower echelons of spirituality
or in higher religions occur
as mere survivals.
Indeed, as originally presented
the theory of animism
is a bit of an embarrassment.
At the same time
the notion that animism
is best understood as a
projection of human experience
onto other forms of life
continues to be debated.
In any event
recent anthropological analysis
has converted its awkward primitivism
into a dazzling array
of tools for thought.
And I'm briefly going
to mention three names,
but you don't need to hold on to them.
So we can read the animist soul
in other terms.
For example
through Bird-David's
Relational Epistemology.
Alongside Descola's interest
in the way human interiority
is attributed to other beings.
Or with Viveiros de Castro
on subject positions,
animism being less a mental state
than a theory of mind.
However,
rather than offering other concepts
and thus transcending the concept of soul,
I want to turn back to it
rather than away from it.
In anthropologist's ceaseless battle
with its own ethnocentrism
one strategy
is not to avoid the weight and freight
of its own vocabulary,
but instead
get up close to it.
This is in order to test its limits.
So precisely in order to
interrogate the concept
I propose to talk of the animist soul
more or less in its Victorian sense.
Among many of Tyler's
contemporaries, after all
it was a counterpart to the kind of soul
they thought they had.
Of course, I've no idea
if Ms. Zweybruck herself
had given much thought to animism.
This returns us to its
present day incarnation.
Think of the legal axiom
that through bequests and such like
a person's will endures
beyond their decease.
In the same way academia
embraces a commitment
to the future of scholarship
that will be carried forward
by diverse minds
sometimes giving the impression
that the mind, thereby, endures.
Here just as the will
only has a future through the good offices
of the heirs
for all that scholars may celebrate
the origination of
ideas in someone's mind.
Tyler's thoughts seemingly
being given a new lease of life
these ideas are now embedded
within a scholarly apparatus
that has a life of its own.
They continue in other minds
as notions refashioned
for other debates.
If this continuity
is immortality of a kind
then it flourishes through specific acts
of regeneration
as when new formulations are acknowledged
and recognized as the rebirth of old ones.
As we leave the staging post behind
it's with the suggestion
that we have in the scholarly circulation
and reinvention of ideas
a model of how people's thoughts
serve as conduits,
channels
for the thoughts of others.
Staging post two.
Prehistoric horticulture.
And I said at the beginning
they'd be rather far apart.
(laughter)
So, this staging post
seems a bit of an outlier.
We find ourselves on Melanesian island
in the Pacific
10 thousand years ago.
Not to linger,
but staying just long enough to introduce
some notable plants.
In fact, Tyler sent us over here
with his remarks on the souls of plants
as a doctrine, I quote
"That lay deep
"In the intellectual
history of southeast asia."
And he was including the Pacific.
We now know
that the exploitation of food crops there
goes back
well before this.
However, 10 thousand
years is interesting to me
as the horizon of an archeological site
in the Mount Hagen area
of western highlands of Papua New Guinea
called Kuk.
And it's spelled K-U-K.
Kuk.
A few miles
from where the first
Australians to come to Hagen
in 1933
set up camp.
That horizon
of 10 thousand years
has yielded evidence of artifacts
and cultivation features
and the years following
such as a stone pestle
used to prepare yams,
along with taro seeds
and starch grains.
Yams and taro
were being exploited at the site
although undisputed
evidence of cultivation
in the form of ditching and
mounding is 3000 years later.
But we are talking of 7000 years ago
and you could orient
this with what you know,
what was happening with rice in China
and of course with the middle east.
These were root crops.
The 1930's Australian patrol
recorded its amazement
at the scale of intensive
cultivation it found.
In the 1930's.
Since then, archeo-botanical work
has shown that Papua New
Guinea was a local site
for the domestication and
dispersal of vegetative crops.
Notably yam and taro,
also banana and sugar cane
and a number of others,
sago and so forth.
Kuk is just one place
on that large island
but it's exceptionally
well documented evidence
has led to the excavation
being nominated for world heritage status.
There is almost nothing to see.
Peering down a trench
during the dig
one might have observed landscape features
a ditch, a mound,
but little more.
The surface is now covered
over for conservation.
But then if you raised your eyes
you would see root crops
very similar to those excavated
on the site, being grown today.
When Europeans first arrived
at coastal and hinterland
parts of Papua New Guinea
in the late 19th and early 20th century,
either yam, or taro
tended to predominate
as the principal subsistence crop.
The principal crop invariably
received ritual attention;
people in fact claiming
that the plants wouldn't grow without it;
and anthropologists have
called the plants artifacts.
Sweet potatoes came along
much later.
Whereas sweet potatoes grow from vines
pushed into the soil
both yam and taro
depend on propagation
through a portion of the tuber or corm
being detached and put aside
from what is eaten
to form the beginnings
of the new plant.
Yams undergo a bifurcated cycle of growth
throwing up vines above ground
that cause nutrients
to be stored below ground
in the tuber.
Taro send up thick stalks
and leaves above ground
and are corm to be replanted
will have some stalk attached.
The bits so planted may be called
the mother, or father
of the child tuber or corm
that grows underground
and only at harvest, of course
is what is underground made visible.
Let's leave here then
but with some sense, perhaps
of what these root crops
might be in Papua New Guinea.
Since the next staging post
is all about taro souls.
So, staging post three.
Taro souls.
An ethno-botanical study
conducted in the 1960's,
it's going to be published
posthumously later this year
describes the horticulture of the Mayengi.
And that is the name of a people
I should coming back to.
The Mayengi of new Britain
off the coast of Papua New Guinea.
Classic animism.
Indeed the description
could have walked off the pages of Tyler.
The cultivators ascribed to taro
their principal food crop
the same theory of the soul
that they entertained of themselves.
The soul was a kind of second self.
A concept Tyler also used
which in the case of people
permeated every part of the body
and was left behind in food remnants
or siting places.
Taro souls
were under the control of various deities.
Masters of taro
who had to be coaxed
into letting the soul
stay attached
to the growing plants.
Like peoples
taro souls make a top
and wander away.
And taro are quick to take offense
if they're not properly cared for.
It is the soul of the taro
that makes the corm heavy and nutritious.
And effort has to be made
to keep the souls tethered to the plants
or the harvest will be worthless.
Now, while each plant
will only be nutritious
if its soul is present
such souls are refractions
of a generic taro soul.
And dedicated action is necessary
to attract as much soul as possible.
You could increase the amount of soul
that a taro has.
You want to attract as much as possible
into the growing taro corm
to make it weighty
and thus satisfy hunger.
There will be plants
who soul fails to grow
just as there are people
in the margins of society
who souls never develop.
Taro soul is as a stalk.
It has to be replenished.
But properly replenished
it exists in perpetuity.
A fractal entity
each particular soul
is also part of generic soul.
The same is true of human beings.
If one thinks, for example
of the perpetuity of
matrilineal kin groups.
The matriclan is at once
itself and everyone
who has been born or will be born.
Listen to this Mayengi comment
on the efforts of patrol officers
to take a population census.
Those young white men
are ridiculous with their roll books.
Why do they count only the living?
Don't they know that the living
are very few in relation to the dead?
If only they could see the spirits
of all the dead.
Spirits of the dead
travel to the origin
places of their matriclan
and whether remembered or forgotten
by living persons
they're part of the present collectivity.
Now if any of you happen to have heard
Gananath Obeyesekere Foerster lecture
on the Trobriand Islands
you may recall the nature
of Trobriand afterlife
from which former clan members are reborn.
But the idea of the soul
as part of a collectivity
isn't peculiar to matriclans.
Herman Strauss,
who was part of the staff
of the Lutheran mission
established in 1934
in the vicinity of that first patrol camp
at Mount Hagen
not far from Kuk
observed something very similar
of Hagen patriclans.
The personal soul
which disappears at death
is a person share
or participation
in the life force of the patriclan.
For as long as they are remembered
particular persons exist
as ancestral spirits
before turning into moths.
People say sometimes.
Perhaps its not the fugitive
future of the personal soul
to which we should be addressing
the question of immortality
but the life force of
which any particular soul
is a part.
Life force,
and I'm sorry about that term
but for want of a better one
has being
in the enduring kinship collectivity
where one soul is also the soul
of others.
We depart from this staging post
noting that such a life force is not inert
but requires replenishment.
Staging post four.
Replacements.
Here is a little detail
that may or may not
reflect the patroness
of the ethnographic record.
Whereas Mayengi ideas about people's souls
can be echoes across the
regions of Papua New Guinea
we can't say the same
of plant souls.
The evidence of an animist attribution
of human-like souls to plant crops
or other living beings
seems much more intermittent.
Thus a recent and very detailed account
of yam cultivation
in another area
identifies people's life force
survives after death in
the form of ancestral power
but could find no obvious connection
to the growing of plants.
There
plants were not said to have souls.
So our classic animist study
is not, after all,
replicated everywhere across Melanesia.
But whatever the reason
for this intermittency
something even more intriguing
comes to light.
Many elements
which in Mayengi are held together
with ideas about the soul
are found numerous ethnographic accounts
in terms of the person-like
characteristics of plants.
And such person-like
characteristics of plants
are there regardless
of whether or not
they're thought to have souls.
Thus yams are said to be
sensitive to people's movements.
Taro and yams both walk about.
Yams flee;
but not from a particular example.
Yams flee gardens when there's a drought.
Something of the primordial
plant is in every plant.
Yams have ideas or listen to people
as do taro.
They may be under the control of spirits
or have their own sources of animation
in the company of their cultivators,
or in the company of other plants.
The constellation of trays varies
but generally the crops don't grow
without kindness and attention.
In other words
there's a broader
and more inclusive sense
of the animatory qualities
of yams and taro
than simply their manifestation
in a doctrine of the soul.
And this shifts one's thoughts a bit
and suggests a parallel.
For similarly,
one can imagine the future rebirth
of the personal soul
or spirit
of people
in other members of a kin group
such as a matriclan
with or without
a specific doctrine about
the soul's journeying.
There is no one story
of rebirth in Papua New Guinea,
or in Melanesia at large.
Differences abound.
Where death is supposed to lead
to reincarnation,
in some areas the moment of rebirth
is left vague and unspecified,
whereas in others it's envisaged
over a specific three generation cycle.
There may be a defuse sense
that spirits return
or none at all.
That is, they just continue their lives
as ancestors influencing
their descendants.
So on analogy
with generalized notions
about the animation of plants
I wonder if notions about reincarnation
are not equally a particular instance
of a more general phenomenon.
In other words.
In the same way as the person
like animation of plants
doesn't require
the notion of a human-like soul,
neither does the reincarnation
of persons.
The more diffuse phenomenon, I suggest
is a concern with replacement.
And I'm translating
an indigenous term.
With the idea that people who die
will be replaced
by specific others.
While this may be elaborators
of three generation process
grandparents and grandchildren
being identified with one another
it's also found in a two-generation form
as between parents and children.
It is among other things
enfolded into marriage rules
as in the claim people
have on formal in-laws
to provide future spouses
which in turn
of course depends on the
discreetness of the kin group
that sees itself being replenished
in this way.
And this seems to be
an immortality of a kind.
The dynamic of replacement
makes sense of the
often fragmentary nature
of stories about the afterlife.
Stories often carry on so far
and the trail vaguely off.
The point is surely
that there is no need
for a continuous narrative
as though the soul had a life history.
Or for narrational
consistency about its return
precisely because replacement
is a self-evident process.
Yet it is concept of replacement
doesn't require a narrative
about happens to
particular personal souls.
The soul may come back into the picture
in another respect.
Namely as part of a generic life force.
From the perspective of the kin group
matri or patriclan
replacement is effected
through the regeneration of group members.
And that implies
that perpetuation of the
collective life force.
And for that
the clan group
forever needs conduits,
needs channels.
Bodily conduits.
One colloquial connotation of replacement
lies in the Hagen idea
that a person recognizes
as his or her particular replacement
a child or some other relative
who has a similar body form
to his or her own.
Nothing to do with
inheritance or succession.
A simple question
of a counterpart likeness
in bodily form.
But what is the body?
We have to turn aside
at the next staging post
for an issue so far evaded.
Staging post five.
The animist body.
We shouldn't be too surprised
to find Tyler
sitting waiting for us
at the bottom of this post.
For among the reasons
the Victorian thinker
gave for rejecting the idea
that the animist soul
could be described as immortal
was the idea that it was
not immaterial enough.
Not spiritual enough.
And I quote
"The soul as recognized in
"Such philosophies."
He means animism.
"Maybe defined
"As an ethereal surviving being
"Concepts of which preceded
"And led up
"To the more transcendental theory
"Of the immaterial and immortal soul
"Which forms part of the theology
"Of higher nations."
He says.
In fact,
he refers to the ethereal substance
of the animist soul.
Mayengi people would be in accord.
The soul, or double self
is said to have a viscous liquid presence
animating at once
the inner and outer form
of a person.
It exists
both sides of the person.
"It would be no exaggeration."
I'm quoting from the ethnographer.
"It would be no exaggeration to say
"That the whole life cycle of the Mayengi
"Is spend in the effort of recovering
"Or keeping these two
souls or selves together.
"While one may be called inner
"And the other, outer soul
"They can only be held together
"By that to which they give life.
"Namely the body
"That after death is no more
"Than an empty husk."
The ethnographer argues
that there is nothing mystical here.
Counterintuitively for us, perhaps
this double self
is captured in terms neither of spirit
nor of substance.
In many respects
it seems easier to apprehend
the Melanesian soul
than to apprehend the Melanesian body.
Perhaps we can call the body
that which is animated.
Reciprocally
it's also that
on which the soul's replenishment
depends.
For the soul needs a container,
a conduit.
And what passes through people's bodies
is in counterpoint
to what passes through
spirit bodies.
In relation to Mayengi taro
in myth,
food is the excrement
of supernatural beings
conveyed by
and coming from their bodies.
While people's bodies
are equally conduits
for the growth and continuity
of taro soul.
Taro soul is augmented
by passing through the bodies of people.
More generally you may say
that the soul requires
this constant replenishment
in the things it animates.
Yet the notion of material substance
clings fast
to the way anthropologists have described
Melanesian conceptualizations of the body.
In life
the body appears to be composed
of substances that circulate
inside and outside blood
and milk, and so forth,
in relation to other bodies.
Just as in death
people treated in terms
of the difference
between flesh that decays
and bones that endure.
In the language they use
Euro-American anthropologists
cannot help giving these aggregations
and disaggregations
a material cast
as in the very notion of substance itself.
But perhaps what we've
learned about the soul
will help here.
I focus on one aspect
of life and death
recognizable across Melanesia
including Mount Hagen.
There seem parallels
between on the one hand
the personal soul that
dissipates after death
and the bodily materials that decompose.
And on the other
what endures of the bones for a while
and continuing identity
for a while
of ancestral spirits.
To the Euro-American observer
the body's materiality
seems especially evident
in the decay and
disappearance of the flesh.
But perhaps we should pay more attention
to that process
of decomposition.
It is regenerative.
Flesh is invariably regarded
as returning to the land
and contributing to the regeneration
of the fertility of the soil.
How so?
Surely because
the vitality its soul gave it.
And do you remember that soul permeates
the living body.
It's that vitality
that is released
into the ground.
In other words,
the very feature
that might suggest the body is material
it's capacity for decomposition
is a flow of life force
the basis of fresh growth.
That same aspect,
bodily decay
is also in Euro-American eyes
a sign of mortality.
Yet in these Melanesian configurations
the constant replenishment of the soil
seems to me
no less immortalizing
than a perpetual replacement of persons
as members of kin groups.
Indeed in many areas
there's a direct connection
for example
through a clan's identification
with its land.
And as the soul
now more generically
life force
travels from one container to another,
it too is replenished
now growing as a person's body,
now growing as fertile soil
and the animate body's human
and non-human
that the soil will produce.
Might we then, in this regard
talk of the immortality of the body.
I turned to notions
about the reincarnation
of food plants.
It's in the treatment of the
dead parts of these plants
that we find a specific justification
for talking about immortality.
We shall catch up with Tyler
at the post after next,
but in the meanwhile
what follows
is obviously speculative.
Staging post six.
The immortality of the body.
As we look around
we can see Kuk again.
You'll recall the
archeological site in Hagen
though from another point of view.
There is not much in
the ethnographic record
that would speak as directly
as I'm going to
although there are plenty
of signs and pointers.
That said, similar reflections
have not escaped
one or two present-day
Papua New Guinean academics.
Notably,
the archeologist John Muke
who was closely involved
with the nomination of
the world heritage site.
He articulated
one of the foundations
on which the nomination was based.
The environs of the site.
As I said, there's
nothing there to be seen
which presents some problems
to the local committee
who needs indicators.
Visible around Kuk, he argued,
was an organically evolved landscape
displaying
the continuing cultivation of plants
to whose early exploitation
the archeology attested.
He also mentioned the perpetual movement
of plants and people across clan groups.
And the value always put
on finding new gardens
for replanting
a circulation already imagined
by the archeologist of a
thousands of years ago.
Now the phrase continuing cultivation
hides an observation
that the linguist-botanist
Andr Haudricourt
made many years ago
of Yam growing in island Melanesia.
Each plant is a clone
of a previous one.
The same genetic individual.
The taro and yams
that Hargon people cultivate
are in this sense
the same individuals.
The clones of those first plants
that were to be cultivated
over the millennia.
And this does not mean
that there was no possibility
of change.
In the words of two archeo-botanists;
and I have to quote them
because I don't really understand this.
(laughter)
"While reproduction involves
the clonal propagation
"From one plant to another
"This does not prevent the formation
"Of novel hybrids or domesticates."
And what they say is
"Though asexual propagation
"Only allows for sematic mutation
"In the genome of the new plants
"Changes to the physical environment
"Can cause favorable and lasting changes
"To the clonal phenotypes,
"And the movement of these varieties
"Within human spaces
"Would have naturally led to the creation
"Of new variants.
"Vegetative or a sexual propagation
"Does not lack change then
"But it does mean that each plant
"Is a clone of a previous one."
They are all one plant.
Now, there is evidence that
in Melanesian horticulture
such propagation was pursued
as a matter of choice.
Many of these plants were capable
of being propagated by seed
but that was ignored
and vegetative propagation
was the preferred method.
Each new plant taking a cutting
or node from a previous one.
And in the case of taro
the stalk is detached
from the corm to be eaten
with a little bit of the parent corm
adhering to it for replanting.
For not so distant neighbors of Mayengi,
though I won't bother you with the name,
another ethnographer of New Britain
says outright
"The taro stalk is immortal."
And she says
"Taro stalks are inherited, traded
"Imported and exported.
"When someone said, this
is my grandfathers taro
"It was clear that it was
not only the same variety
"As the grandfather had planted,
"But was considered to
be the identical stalk
"That the grandfather had planted.
"The taro stalk has an immortality
"That is taken as a human model.
"In some instances
"The history of a specific variety
"Parallels that
"Of a genealogical descent group.
"In others of a local group.
"And in yet others
"Offers a personal history
"As to who first imported it.
"Above all, the identification
of the present planter
"With his or her predecessor
"The one who he or she has replaced
"Is repeated over and again.
"Both men and women desire replacements.
"With the next generation
in sight, however
"Anticipating their replacement
"Also anticipates their death.
"And the same is true of plants.
"Without going into detail
"It's the bit of the corm or tuber
"That is cut off,
"Or otherwise separated
from what is to be eaten
"That provides the nourishment
"For the new corm or tuber
"That grows in its stead.
"What is eventually harvested
"Is in effect a replacement
"For the piece that was planted.
"If you could imagine as a parent
"Where the father or mother
"Who dries up, shrivels and dies away."
There's an observation to be made here.
We do not need to decide
Whether the discarded part of the plant
and what is growing in its place
is soul or substance.
We don't need to decide.
Not just because of the
impossibility of these terms
but because unlike the demands
of the world heritage nomination,
we don't require a doctrine of continuity
that would have to trace
the past and future
of these elements.
There is no need to narrativize the soul
or have a theory about
continuous material regeneration.
On the contrary,
if we were to ally
the botanists knowledge
of vegetative reproduction
through cloning
with these indigenous actions
that ensure perpetual replacement
our attention would be elsewhere.
It would be on the repeated breaks
with the previous generation.
The repeated cuts.
The repeated deaths
required for the next
generation to spring anew.
Thus, among some present-day people
at Kuk
where heritage debates
might suppose claims
about unbroken continuity
the kind of continuity that John Muke,
the Papua New Guinea
Archeologist was pointing to
seems closer to an analogy.
And this certainly,
at least how some Hagen
people also express it.
They say they can't possibly know
who it was who cultivated this area
millennia ago.
But those people's actions and practices
were like those of today
and today's people
now live there in their stead.
What is evident
is the replacement
just as in the clan child
or the plant offspring.
Repeated cuts,
repeated deaths.
So, what is death?
We turn up at the penultimate staging post
where Tyler's shadow can be seen again
and are going to stay here
little bit longer.
Staging post seven,
life and death.
Something Tyler
said about the animist soul
comes back to mind.
Apropos the spiritual aspects of the soul
in the theology of higher nations,
he talks of the immaterial
and immortal soul
as a transcendental one.
The life of the soul surpasses
other forms of existence.
We may add that the very formulation
holds transcendental possibility.
A transcendentalist view
at once embraces ideas
of both transcendence
and imminence,
while also supposing imminence
as it's transcended opposite.
Thus it can suggest
which is as far as Tyler goes
that there are lower beliefs and practices
locked into
some kind of pre-transcendental state.
In that state of affairs
there's no life or power
beyond what is already imminent
in the mundane world.
Whether we go back to the axial age
or to the countless reformations
of Christian history
transcendence in the perspective
from which immanentism
in whatever form
can emerge as an apparently counter
set of beliefs and practices.
As to what has to be over come
in transcendentalist thinking,
in the case of persons,
this generally entails
some aspect of their being
or selfhood.
One answer
that must have been familiar
to Tyler's 19th century contemporaries
with those higher religions in mind
is obvious.
What is overcome is mortality.
It follows that if it's the
soul that transcends death
then some other part
of the person must die
from which comes a particular imagining
of the material mortal body.
Death this implies a cessation
of non spiritual life
the end of the life course
in the present world.
That radical disjuncture
also requires
though only dies once.
And we'll come back to that.
Not in Tyler's terms
but as a legacy of his writing
I want to suggest that
the concept of immanentism
turns out to be unexpectedly helpful.
Understood as a mode of existence
that resides within, or
permeates being in the world
it allows me
to give a half turn to the
question I started with.
I had wondered
if we might ask about
immortality in immanest thought
Melanesian-speaking.
So let me rephrase that.
The question becomes
what would everlasting life
for an immanentist existence look like?
And it carries a corollary.
What would death look like?
First then, immanentist life.
By definition
such life is discoverable anywhere
though people may formulate
it in different ways
for persons plants or animals.
Entities that Euro-Americans
would regard as inanimate
such as features of the landscape
maybe addressed as personal beings.
As a force of growth or regeneration
life is present in the
form things take and trees
grow in the flourishing of children,
in good health and so forth.
It implies an active positive condition
often additionally secured
through invisible
but present beings
such as ancestral ghosts.
And is made visible
in the health and brightness
of enduring vitality.
Mayengi would say that these show
how much soul one has.
Such life is everlasting
because people take steps to perpetuate it
through appropriate
rituals or cult activity.
They intervene to ensure his perpetuation.
Whether on a routine basis
through spells or magic
to make things grow
or in an occasional basis
by bringing in spirit beings
as special concentrations of life force.
In other words
they immortalize themselves
and what sustains them.
In fact, one might say
that life in this sense
is the mortalizing set of
actions that people take
in order to perpetuate their being.
We might even say
that the only life that can be lived
is life everlasting.
In so far as the evidence for vitality
and thus the flourishing of people
is there in the antecedent generations
that brought them into
being and will exist
in the future generations
that replace them.
Moreover, as we saw in
the case of the cycling
of Mayengi taro souls
people don't just draw on
such generative capacities
a source of life for themselves
they are also conduits
for its perpetuation.
Equally significantly then
peoples actions are important
for replenishing this power.
Life has to be regenerated.
People have to plant
and they have to procreate.
But this sense of procreation
is perhaps closer
to that of cloning
than of lineality.
Depending on where one is in Melanesia
collectivities of kin
perpetually replace themselves.
The point is that there must
be forth coming generations
who will be the future channels
or conduits of life
like the tubers that
spring anew from the soil.
This kind of immanentist life
does not culminate
in a higher order of being
but inheres in the deliberate regeneration
of the present order of being
to which everything belongs.
So what about immanentist death?
Well, you can imagine
what I'm going to say.
If life is all around and everlasting,
so too death is all
around and everlasting.
It's not the same as life.
Rather, it's the condition of existence
that makes people work so hard
at being alive.
It is what makes life an achievement.
In truth, people die all the time.
As when their souls,
their invisible selves
wander away when they're sleeping
or get captured by others.
The botanist Haudricourt
tells of an encounter on
the dock side in Port Vila
Vanuatu,
between two men who imagined
they recognize one another.
One of them
thinking the other is the
long deceased relative
whispers to him
"Are you dead or alive?"
Rather than a sate of finality
death is an ever-present possibility
for a person's invisible self.
Indeed when it's held in a person,
life or life force is
under constant attack,
whether from malevolent
sorcery, or malicious enemies,
or ancestral ghosts with withdraw support.
Someone's innards may be eaten by a which
but sown up again
and the victim doesn't know
he or she
has only a short while left.
The very fact that life
force permeates the body
means that it is present in it
vulnerable to manipulation
by death dealing others.
A person dies once and for all
only when their invisible self
succumbs to an attack
that is irreversible.
In other words,
they can no longer keep
their soul or souls together
with the body as the soul's container.
In the language I've been using
They've ceased to be a conduit
for the increase of life force.
Like a Mayengi taro
without its invisible self,
the body without a soul cannot survive
to nourish others in that form.
And of course it's routinely reported
that morning for a person starts
once their soul is departed
and assumes there are
signs of it's departure
the body is bound to drop away
because life continues in other persons.
If life is part of a generic life force
sustained through
particular people's actions,
so death, we may say, is
part of a death force.
As has been described for
Hagen people around Kuk
everything that exists
can be seen as a transmitter of the forces
of life or death.
Death is imagined as a specific agency
penetrating the world of human affairs.
And every irreversible death
comes from malign will of spirits or men.
That is from an attack on the life force.
I quote the aim of sorcerers
to the destroy the soul
of the life force of
the person to be killed.
And this is the missionary
anthropology Strauss
whom I mentioned before
who'd been at Kuk in the area
since the 1930's.
For which one needs something,
within which the soul of
the person is contained.
Or bits of the soul like left over food,
or discarded garments,
or simply a persons name.
And it's possible in this way
to take revenge for an injury
without recourse to fighting.
It all happens invisibly.
One can destroy an enemy
by having a ritual expert
call on the enemy's name
through which one enlists
his ancestral spirit
so they hand over his soul.
One more comment on death.
On analogy with the life
that springs anew
in the newly growing
taro corm or yam tuber
the falling away of the husk
that was initially planted
as the offspring's mother or father
also seems a regenerative moment.
That wasting and decay
enables new life
which is itself the parent
in a transformed state.
It's a form of death
that is not a finality
to be overcome
or transcended.
Rather, it's an instrument
of everyday,
non-miraculous rebirth.
We've come to the...
Not worrying about the time, I hope.
We've just come to the last
staging post, number eight.
Souls in other selves.
I've obviously trod a very selective path
from post to post.
Among innumerable
combinations and permutations
in how people frame life and death.
I focused on only two kinds of food plants
and while the horizon
of 10 thousand years ago
was introduced partly to
put the last 60 or 100 years
into perspective as a very recent epoch
I've ignored even more
recent ways of life.
But these qualifications aside
let me reflect
on what has emerged about
Melanesian immanentism.
It's important to appreciate
that the everlasting character
of both life and death
does not imply endless continuity
or lack of change.
To the contrary.
People's interest
in the replacement
of a life force
whether in themselves
or the crops that are
so much of themselves
is also an interest
in the displacement
of one life by another.
Gardeners, for example
are always looking
for new varieties of food crops
to plant.
The process of keeping life going
is never straight forward,
always requires work,
ritual and otherwise.
And moving from one moment to the next,
this replacement
which is also a displacement
is disjunctive.
The life force that infuses any
particular soul
must enter fresh conduits
other selves.
Perhaps we now have some sense
of the immanentist soul
for these horticulturalists.
While we may appreciate
Tyler's healthy skepticism
about reading 19th century
theological notions
into the animism of other cultures
he pursued a relation
between the material and immaterial.
Indeed the Victorians over compensated
in their auto-critique.
Criticizing the assumption
that the soul is invariably
a spiritual being
they stressed the materiality
of animist notions,
and of course, the accessibility
of the spirit world at large
to human needs and desires,
overplaying the material and mundane,
and reserving for themselves
a different kind of spirituality.
A transcendental move
if there was one.
But Ms. Zweybruck wonderful rubric
concerning immortality
has lifted us out if this.
We simply do not need to concern ourselves
with the relation between body and soul
in the terms of materiality
and spirituality;
the material and the immaterial.
I threw in a playful aside
on the immortality of the body
just to underlie
the ambiguities these terms introduce.
I hasten to add
in that case,
that this isn't getting rid of a binary
for the sake of doing so.
On the contrary.
There's a powerful binary at play
in these immanentist
worlds, but it's not this.
We've already encountered it
at one or two junctures.
The contrast between what is seen
and what exists unseen.
Melanesians are constantly testing
what it is they see.
Are you a living man or a dead one
was the whisper.
The unseen is many registers
from the secrecy that excludes
some
to whole invisible counter worlds.
And although of another time and place
I'm reminded of Mariane Ferme's
The Underneath of Things.
What is invisible
works as a motivating
potentially activating state of affairs
of which visible appearance
may, or may not
offer a cue.
In effect, this is a pairing
that may be turned inside out.
We might say that the visible
and the invisible
adhere to each other
rather like Mayengis
outer and inner souls.
At the outset
I remarked on the kind of immortality
that the circulation of ideas
in the academy suggests.
Not only in the notion
that one person's ideas
maybe reborn as another's
but also that they are
purposefully regenerated.
Perhaps that makes less strange
some of these immanentist notions,
despite, of course
different orientations
in many other respects.
As to purposeful regeneration, however
let me be explicit
about what we might,
or might not want
to keep of Tyler's doctrine of souls.
As we've heard,
Tyler tied immortality
to a notion of an enduring
immaterial spiritual life.
In animism
he demonstrated over and again
to his own satisfaction
that what might look like
a notion of immortality
was diminished
by not being immaterial enough.
Thus, he wrote
"Granted that the soul
survives the death of the body
"Instance after instance from the records
"Shows this soul to be regarded
"As a mortal being
"Liable like the body itself
"To accidents and death."
In retrospect
we can see
that combining immortal an immaterial
is simply repeated
in his opposite
the identification
of the mortal with the material,
and it's not helpful.
What we might like to keep
is that in talking about soul
he found a common language
with his contemporaries
for all that he wished to disabuse them
of misconceptions about the origins
of religious thought.
The problem of language recurs,
is born over and again.
An English speaker cannot talk of soul
with his opposite body,
and body is the mortal bit.
Take that opposition away
and one subject matter seems to vanish.
So rather than throwing out the concepts
The anthropologist may set them spinning
as I've tried to do here.
I have tethered the account instead
to areas of Melanesian
horticultural practice
insofar as these provide
a specific model
for thinking of everlasting life.
Less, perhaps
as an immortality frozen
at the moment of death
as in
some Euro-American views
than as ceaseless regeneration.
If we can identify as something
as appropriate to call soul
and refer to its rebirth
within a kinship community,
it can also be identified
in the constant return
of fleshly nourishment
to the soil and its cultivation
and Melanesians themselves
may express this
by drawing attention to the life cycles
of the taro and yams they cultivate.
Long ago
Haudricourt offered an apt formula.
Apropos Melanesia,
people are cultivated during
their lifetime, he said.
And indeed
planted is the way
we would have to translate
human in Hagen idiom,
as the Kuk archeologist Muke also attests.
And they cease to be cultivated at death.
Ms. Zweybruck interest in immortality
has opened up what it means
that such being are no longer themselves.
Cultivated
they survive now
in the life of others.
I have
a very brief postscript if you will allow.
If you'll just indulge me.
This is a postscript
for the anthropologists who are here.
Ms. Zweybruck interest in immortality
is not irrelevant
to the 20th century anthropology
that flourished after animism
had disappeared as a topic.
There was a long period
when aspects of societies
that might formally have
been called animistic
were studied under the
rubric of categories
more compatible
with self-acknowledged
modern institutions
such as politics, economics,
religion and so forth.
For British social anthropologists
like myself
the social turn
that followed Durkheim's
transformative formula.
Religion is society worshiping itself
meant that there was a
great swing of interest
towards social organization
including the prominence of institutions
such as dissent groups
that is the interactions
of clan and kin collectivities.
This was a notable example
of anthropological rejuvenation and demise
for dissent groups were
discovered in Melanesia
and then discarded.
The point to extract
is that when they were
occupying center stage
these constructs made
a kind of immortality
visible to the anthropologist.
As anthropologist uncovered
the powers and circumstances
of a markedly social life
where political or economic interests
were seen to shape religious precepts
or kinship obligations,
they also brought attention
the dynamics of a self regenerating
social formation,
perpetual succession,
society enduring in its structures,
rolls reproduced,
and so forth.
Perhaps those immortal dissent groups
have since been
too quickly dispatched
from anthropological purview.
Indeed, one might revisit analyses
of the way in which people are,
or are not caught up in kin groups
as a model of self-formation
that also a collective formation.
In order to query
an axiomatic assumption
that ran through the
early animist literature.
And I end on this point.
This was the assumption
that people's personal awareness
of their experience as sentient beings
projected, it was argued
onto their environment
is sufficient to account
for their apprehensions
and ideas.
The notion that how
people perceive themselves
is projected onto other entities
normalizes the soul
as originating within the human being.
Now, it's no doubt going too far
to suggest that people
gave themselves the souls
they already recognized in other selves,
human or non-human.
But in any event
that notion of projection
has often rendered mute
the state of affairs
encountered in immanentist regimes
and people's immortalizing work
in keeping the world going.
Thank you very much.
(applause)
- [Paula] I'd really like
to thank professor Strathern
for making the world feel so much richer
and a lot more crowded, I would say.
(laughter)
Professor Strathern will take questions
and Ellen will take the
microphone around and...
- We ask that you
make these questions
and make them brief
so everyone who
would like to ask something
has time to do so.
So please raise your hand
if you have a question.
- [Marilyn] I have hearing problems
so I need to come close to you
despite your microphone.
- [Woman] I won't yell loudly then.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
As an archeo-botanist
I just love this.
- Oh, thank you.
- [Woman] But I did want
to ask you something
that maybe too specific for your talk.
Anna Meigs has been a big influence on me
and she talks about this
life force called new Nu.
And I'm assuming you know about that
because it's from--
- This is Anna Sing.
- [Woman] No, Meigs.
- Oh, sorry.
- [Woman] Meigs.
Anna Meigs.
- Oh sorry, I beg your pardon.
- [Woman] Meigs.
- Oh Anna Meigs, yes of course.
- [Woman] Yes.
- I know Anna Meigs.
- [Woman] Right, Nu.
And I'm assuming
that's a version of the life force
you were talking about.
- Absolutely, yes.
- [Woman] Would you say it's the same
or different, how is it?
Because the focus that she talks about
is people gain life force through eating.
Eating the food that's being generated--
- Exactly.
- [Woman] In the garden.
And that is
certainly part of what
you were talking about
but you didn't say anything about that.
If you could comment about
eating.
- Absolutely.
What she says is absolutely correct.
That is part
of the whole cycle.
And in course in eating
your also eating
in those places that
regard plants having souls
and not all do.
But you are
channeling the vitality
of the plants as well
in that process.
Both sides are nourished.
It's a mutual nourishment in a sense.
Which is a non-consuming metaphor
if anybody wants to ask
what the relevant of this is
to 21st century.
(laughter)
- Surely there's at
least one more question.
- [Woman] As a comment.
This is coming from Tibetan Buddhism.
(laughter)
So, there are three bodies
that emanate dharmakaya,
sambhogakaya,
and nirmanakaya
It's this eminence
of presence in being
and everything appears
in permanence.
So it follows very nicely.
I really appreciated what you had to say.
And it's interesting
how different traditions
have very similar--
- Yes.
- [Woman] Truth.
There's only one reality.
- But shouldn't I be
uncomfortable about that?
- [Woman] How so?
- Shouldn't I regard
forms Buddhism
as belonging to the transcendental?
- [Woman] It depends on
what kind of Buddhism
your talking about.
- Of course.
- [Woman] Yes.
(laughter)
- Sorry.
- Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
- [Man] Thank you very much Marilyn.
I want to talk about the people
with whom I've worked Inuit, or Eskimos
in northern Canada
because the kind of
arguments about immortality
have a great relevance today.
One of which is the Canadian
sorrow and anger
at the enormous suicide rate
amongst the indigenous peoples.
Particularly the Inuit.
Particularly young men.
But the Inuit have
explicitly or tacitly
a belief in three souls.
One of which is a breath soul
that leaves you when you die.
Breath is a soul.
The other one
it's a...
I guess it's more like the
kinds of soul
that
when you die goes somewhere
but it doesn't reenter you.
But the most important one
is the name.
The name is the person, is the soul.
And when a child is about to be born
somebody is calling
the name of a past person,
and when it is, its name, it comes out.
And, of course
this means that they don't
designate men or women.
So you are,
you may be called by your mother,
grandfather or great uncle
or something like that
because that's who you are,
which is one of the reasons
that children are treated
with some respect,
or supposed to be.
But nowadays
the Canadian government
and many other people
are really worried
about the high suicide rate.
But from the point of view
of many of the young people
and this is the work of Lisa Stevenson
who got a Ph.D. at
Berkeley a few years ago.
They say, well
my friend dies recently
or my friend committed suicide recently.
And he's up there
and I'd love to join him.
I miss him.
I don't particularly like it here anyhow.
So
maybe I'll go off in my
truck and shoot myself
or otherwise commit suicide.
Then, I'll see who I become the next time.
After all,
I've been alive for thousands of years.
I am the same person
for thousands of years.
- [Marilyn] Fascinating, thank you.
Thank you for that.
Put it in a nut shell.
- [Woman] I am curious about the structure
of your talk.
The eight posts.
- [Marilyn] Yes.
- [Woman] Have you used that before
in giving a talk?
- [Marilyn] Well
I wasn't showing any slides.
There was no relief from the text.
- [Woman] Right.
(laughter)
- So I thought
it might actually help
if there was a little joke
that recurred
at intervals.
But it also enabled me to do
something of course
which I have used
many times,
which is to juxtapose
quite different material.
I think I should bring it together.
That is device.
You start far apart
and then by the end
you put it together.
And that's a device I'd often use, yes.
But on this occasion
it was because
there was no other relief.
- [Woman] It worked beautifully.
And I think it did help
the listener to also visualize
the posts
and urged us
to make connections.
- [Marilyn] They ruined
my head, about this high.
- [Woman] Oh yeah.
(laughter)
And you transmitted that to ours as well.
Thank you.
(laughter)
- Thank you so much.
I really appreciate that comment.
- [Man] Since you have
reanimated for us animism
I wonder of you can
also reconstitute for us
where we stand
as something that's not animistic.
You mentioned Euro-America
or something like that
which sounds like
Disneyland, or something.
- [Marilyn] Yes.
- [Man] But how would you characterize
this Euro-American idea
insofar as it's different from animism?
- Yes.
Perhaps I should make very clear.
I'm not actually doing a comparison
between Euro-American
societies and cultures
and these other Melanesian
societies and cultures.
And those two terms
are not on a par
even though I label them
as though they are.
The point is that
the language through which I'm describing
what I'm trying to describe in Melanesia
is of itself os a particular historical
cultural moment.
And it is labeling that moment.
So I am actually labeling
the language I use
as Euro-American.
I think that's probably
the best way I can;
but as to, well.
Sorry.
I'm getting really out of my depth here.
But insofar as that little contrast
between transcendentalism and immanentism
has any force,
it is of course countlessly reinvented
at every moment
of religious
reformation
of diverse kinds
for 2000 years
as far as Christianity.
So, things are identified
as one or the other, constantly.
So it's a constantly reinvented
duo.
Which means that we
shouldn't be at all surprised
to find ourselves doing
immanentist things.
That's not an issue.
The only thing is
that if you start talking that way
then you evoke
a problem sometimes
because they look as though
you're being superstitious
or you're not being rational.
Or whatever, whatever.
But it's not a problem
that the immanentists I'm talking about
have.
It's only a problem of
immanentist behavior
within a transcendentalist position.
But I'm sorry about those awkward terms.
- [Ellen] We have time
for one more question.
There will be time after the lectures
if you'd like to speak
to professor Strathern.
- [Woman] Thank you.
- [Marilyn] Sorry.
- [Woman] Thank you so much for the talk.
I have a more personal question
for how you decided
the topic of this,
I know it's linked to the lecture
but where does your inspiration
to think about concepts
the way think.
And thinking through relations
with relations come from.
It's like this memories
from your experience
in Melanesia?
Or, do you need to go back
to conversations.
Do you need to go personally back there?
I'm just wondering
where these kind of
force come from
that makes you think
from the limit.
Yeah.
- [Marilyn] Alright, thank you.
That's actually a very important question.
Because I've been doing
what many scholars do
which is mingle their thoughts
in with the material
that they're trying to describe.
In one sense that's completely
unavoidable.
Because you can only order that material
by conceptualizing it
in certain ways.
Actually,
that's one thing I could say in my favor.
Don't let me forget it.
(laughter)
Clenched my hand.
You're completely right
to ask the question
because one has to keep that process
really under control.
One has to be constantly self-scrutinizing
the categories
through which one's
thinking and presenting.
I don't know how
familiar you are with
anthropological procedures
but everything I've talked about
is rooted in descriptions.
It will be made
by numerous anthropologists
across Melanesia.
So almost all my
baseline
observations are documented by others
and that's what I mean
by referring to ethnographic accounts.
Then of course I've spun things
because of the pleasure of spinning.
(laughter)
But in my own favor
I will say that
one or two Papua New Guinea academics
who've read the Gender of the Gift
think it gives a reasonable
account.
So,
I think maybe the
spinning sometimes works.
(laughter)
(applause)
(soft music)